when can a matrix be called singular the
definition is very simple its singular
if its determinant equals zero that's
how simple the definition is we say that
matrix a is singular if the determinant
of a is equal to zero else it will be
non singular if the determinant is equal
to 0 then singular and if the
determinant is nonzero then the matrix
is non-singular just remember this
nonzero non singular hand needless to
say we are only talking about square
matrices here because only square
matrices can have determinants so we can
say that a square matrix is singular if
its determinant is 0 and non singular if
its determinant is nonzero we should try
out a couple of examples now is this
matrix a singular - no if it's singular
we need to find its determinant what is
the determinant of a it will be this
product minus this product 1 multiplied
with 8 minus 4 multiplied with 2 8 minus
8 will give us 0 the determinant of a is
0 which means that matrix a is singular
determinant 0 then singular ok next
matrix matrix B singular or non singular
pause and try to know the
answer we need to find the determinant
of B it will equal 3 times 2 minus 4
times 1 6 minus 4 gives us - because
it's nonzero we can say that matrix B is
non singular but why is this concept
important where do we apply it we use it
to find the inverse of a matrix but how
to know the answer you'll have to watch
the next video
you